hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the fiday grand
Swiss I decided to cover it's from the
pen ultimate run and it's abanu Mishra
versus vasel Ian which makes makes it a
really wonderful pairing abanu Mishra is
the youngest grandm in the world and the
last time I said it I thought okay that
sounds a bit weird he's not currently
the youngest Grandmaster in the world uh
he achieved his grander Grandmaster
title at the youngest age that anyone
was ever able to do he beat Serge
karakin record and he became a
Grandmaster at the age of 12 Years 4
months and 25 days he's currently 14
years old and he is on a mission to
become the youngest world champion ever
uh on the other hand you have asley vuk
who is um well on a good day he's a
nightmare to any player he can defeat
everyone and he can he he can just if he
has a great day he can definitely crush
a world champion and he's been a grand
master since 1988 and interestingly in
1988 he also entered the world top 10
that's just how strong he was so he
became a grand master and immediately
entered the the world top 10 in
classical rating so let's check it out
as it's uh it's a really weird game
where uh not a lot seems to be happening
but then all of a sudden it's Checkmate
and there's nothing you can do so let's
check it out abanu has the white pieces
and he opened with E4 we have a very
well-known line of the Sicilian Defense
Knight F3 D6 we have D4 captures
captures and now Knight to F6 we have
Knight to C3 and Knight to C6 Bishop to
G5 the r Rouser variation and now Pawn
to E6 Queen to D2 and pawn to A6 now
taking away the B5 Square from the from
the white Knights uh Knight captures and
C6 we have B captures and now queenside
castles now all been play before nothing
new here Bishop D7 is the standard move
here however uh vasel goes for Pawn to
D5 right away he strikes in the center
and now we have Queen to E3 it's sort of
a
maybe a tricky line where you try to get
this maybe bishop captures and F6 G
captures and Bishop to C4 in uh but it
it's not all that spectacular for white
at least not at a moment of course you
want to do this at some point and REM
maneuver your Bishop to B3 as um IAS
will have the semiopen B file to use to
attack the white king uh but what abanu
goes for is a little bit better he goes
for Queen A3 so he keeps the tension and
now you always have to worry about this
captures on D5 since the king is still
on E8 and also E5 could be very annoying
due to the pin here so Bishop to E7 and
only now Bishop captures uh so you you
cannot capture with the bishop if you
capture with the bishop now this will be
a problem as you will blunder a pawn
here this is now impossible so instead
after Bishop captures we have G captures
and now Bishop to C4 so a similar but
you've also now opened up the G file as
well as the B file so black does have
the semi-open B file and the sem open G
file but the question is what will you
do with your king So Bishop to B7 and
now Rook H to E1 uh getting your pieces
fully developed and now we have Pawn to
H5 usually uh Queen to C7 is a moveie
you want to play here as the The Rook
here is on D1 H but no we have Pawn to
H5 and here abim Manu says all right if
you want to keep your king in the center
of the board and the queen uh let's open
up the position e captures on D5 C
captur and Bishop captures on D5 he
sacrifices a piece to open up the center
e captures Knight captures Bishop
captures and The Rook captures on D5
attacking the black queen and event just
plays Queen to C7 and he asks all right
I'm up a piece what are you really
threatening here so okay abanu plays
Rook to C5 Bishop of course cannot move
and if the queen captures well then
Queen captures and you will not be able
to capture back as the bishop is spinned
so something else must be played
uh Queen to D Queen to D6 is probably
best it's uh forcing repetition because
now there's really nothing better than
then to just repeat moves here and we
would most likely see a draw by
three-fold repetition but vasel went
back and now he allows this very very
strong Queen to F3 move but abanu for
some reason doesn't play it right away
he first wants to check uh maybe if
vasel really does not want a repetition
here because it's not easy to calculate
all the way and vasel says Queen to C7
to C5 and he goes back Queen to d8 he
does not go Queen to D6 so Queen back to
d8 and now abanu say all right now Queen
to F3 and we reach the position from the
thumbnail where you are putting pressure
on The Rook here you are threatening to
pick up the H5 pawn and also if black
doesn't do anything about the king queen
captures on F6 will land and that will
be very very hard to defend so King to
f8 it is the strongest move and now AB
be mind you just captures on H5 yes
you're down a piece but your King's uh
your opponent's king is in a really bad
spot here and you will have three points
on the king side to start pushing you're
now up three pawns which is enough
compensation for the piece even if we
eliminate the queen and the Rooks from
the board uh this it's it's still only
white who can win this uh so uh not
something you you want to do of course
it'd be much better if white first
Advanced the pawns as much as far as
possible and then went into an end game
uh but yeah black is not winning this
however you play it Rook captures on H5
Queen cap on H5 and now believe it or
not you have to play King to E8 it's
such an ugly move putting the king in
front of the Rook like this but the
point is after Queen to h8 check King to
D7 and Rook to D1 check you can block
with Bishop to D6 and still it's uh I
mean yes you are still up a piece but
it's an open board the king is the king
can be checked from from any possession
and now abim Manu will of course start
advancing those uh kingside pawns and
again it's only abanu who can win this
game game however uh he played King to
G7 which is fine unless abanu finds the
only way to actually win the game uh
it's sort of a mixture of will you
Checkmate the black king or will you win
a lot of material so feel free to pause
the video and figure out how to do it
while I give you a couple of seconds it
it's it is what you think but you have
to look a bit further just you know to
cement it
properly
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always going
for a very nice Rook lift and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook the E3 no doubt that this is
the move you've all found and of course
the Rook to G3 will end in Checkmate
after King to f8 and queen to h8 but
what if Bishop to D6 as this is what
vasel played what now you found Rook to
E3 and what was your move after Bishop
to D6 that is the real question here and
the answer is only one move and that is
Queen to G4 with check King to f8 and
now Rook H3 threatening Rook to h8 to
win The Black Queen on d8 and after King
to E7 now Queen to E4 with check King to
D7 of course if you could play Bishop E5
it'd be great but F4 just wins that
Bishop so you have to move the king king
to D7 and now Queen to B7 with check and
now you can block with the queen because
you lose The Rook you cannot block with
the bishop because you lose the queen
after Rook to D3 with check so you again
have to move the king king to E8 was
played and only now Rook to h8 with
check and that's all there is Bishop to
f8 blocking and now Rook to H7 going
after Checkmate here and the only way to
defend Checkmate is to either move the
queen but then you lose the Rook or to
move the bishop Bishop to E7 was played
but now just Queen to C6 with check and
he was in this position on move 31 that
vlean chuk resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here it's a
really crazy position where if you block
with the queen of course you have to
give up The Rook or even better Rook to
h8 check and then after Bishop to f8 now
you take and after the queen blocks now
you just trade everything you can
capture here and then pick up the queen
you're going to be up a full queen of
course completely winning and if you
don't do that if you start running away
with the King it's not much better
because you will now play Queen captur
on A8 a temporary Queen sacrifice but
nothing to worry about just Queen
captures on A8 uh Rook to HH check King
G7 and now Queen captures on A8 and
that's all there is you have a rook for
a bishop you're up three pawns
completely winning however you play it
uh you
know literally anyone anyone could win
this without um putting in much thought
into this so of course after Queen to C6
check vasel resigned and a wonderful
victory for the uh youngest ever
Grandmaster abim Manu Mishra uh we'll
see how he does I think he got like five
and a half in the tournament let me just
check I don't know uh the final
standings yeah he got five and a half
out of 11 which got him
to uh yeah he he finished the tournament
as number 59 so could be a little bit
better but nothing uh not terrible he
lost his first run to Alexis Sana and he
lost to Alan Pisha all the other games
either a victory or a draw he defeated
Alexander donchenko and Vasan chuk and
got a lot of dra draws against some very
strong Grand Masters uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it thank
you a lot for recommending it really is
a wonderful one and it really is a fine
matchup Vasan chuk the the you know the
the the most fearsome player who ever
lived you know he was the the everyone
who played him just feared playing
against him because he was so strong he
he won everything he was uh absolutely
incredible in his prime and even now
when he has a good day he will crush
everyone against the youngest Grand
Master in the world very very nice
matchup uh so once again really you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Gart
hlan perfor love Marie India Florida
iguana and tortois breeders and Carrie
Elis rodella for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World H so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day